Kellyanne Conway serves as counselor to
the president she joins us now from
Washington only on CBS this morning
good morning Kelly Anne good morning
Nora should Deborah Ramirez the new
Cavanaugh accuser be allowed to testify
if she would like to she can certainly
contact the chairman of the Senate
Judiciary Committee they have a process
in place obviously they've made
tremendous on precedent accommodations
for Ms Ford to testify on Thursday judge
Kavanagh has been willing to testify
publicly to what he has said privately
under oath from day one less than 24
hours after he was made aware of the
identity of Miss Ford of dr. Ford he
said he would raise his right hand and
testify add to his 30-plus hours of
testimony answers to 1,300 written
questions in the Senate confirmation
hearing and I thought that his comment
last night about the second so-called
accuser is incredibly instructive he's
not calling this a smear campaign indeed
this is starting to feel like a vast
left-wing conspiracy the New York Times
says that they interviewed dozens nor
dozens of people over the last couple
weeks trying to verify the second
accusation and they couldn't go forward
with the reporting not because they are
supportive of president Trump's Supreme
Court nominees but because they have
some standards and they could not come
forward and in fact the New York Times
also reports that Ms Ramirez was asking
people if they remembered and telling
them that she couldn't be sure either
Norah I know there's pent up demand for
women to get their day women who have
been sexually harassed and sexually
assaulted and I personally am very
aggrieved for all of them but are we
going to put decades of pent up demand
for women to feel whole on one man's
shoulders what exactly is the standard
for ruining one man's life based on
decades of allegations that have nothing
to do with him visiting upon other men
including in the media but that that to
me then Kellyanne begs the question you
have two accusers who have come forward
clearly there is still a lot of
questions shouldn't there be an
investigation a thorough investigation
and the confirmation process put on hold
until these accusers have a chance to
have their day in court and you've heard
Michael avenatti now says that there's a
third accuser who's coming forward this
week should the confirmation process be
put on hold
it has been put on hold Gail it's been
on hope it's been put on hold for weeks
now because senator Feinstein sat on the
first accusers letter and then someone
in the Democratic Committee we suppose a
staffer breach the anonymity and divulge
the identity this woman who wanted to
remain private okay no because of the
republic's you didn't continue to be put
on hold we know it's been put on hold
but now you have two people in a third
coming should it continue to be put on
hold
I'm sorry Yellen let's make very clear
the third woman is also from high school
I just wanted to say that this may be
the first time we've ever heard of
allegations against someone as a
teenager who did not prey upon women
thusly as he became powerful
as you know full well at CBS News it's
when men become powerful and think that
they can use women and and interrupt
their careers if they want to for their
own predatory proclivities that then
they that then they start preying upon
women the allegations against judge
Kavanaugh are often when he was a
teenager and then we're supposed to
believe he's a judge of a dozen years
hiring female law clerks to boot and
he's alone with them plenty and yet
there's and they support his nomination
in the Supreme Court this is all very
relevant because everything that's being
said is not does not comport with the
judge Cavanaugh that all these women who
have dealt with him in pressure
situations throughout his adult life in
his career have said about him would be
hearing his Thursday if people who want
to testify under oath should come and
testify there's a process in place the
Senate Judiciary Committee has been very
accommodating and all the Democrats
every single one who are calling for
delay delay obstruction resistance
already said they wouldn't vote for
judge Kavanagh carry on his politics
I'd like to get your sense of something
the president said you spent your career
learning about Women Voters and women
consumers the president in response to
this dr. Ford's allegation said I have
no doubt that if the attack on dr. Ford
was as bad as she says charges would
have been immediately filed based on
your understanding of women is it
something that that happens often that
women have a sexual assault encounter
and then don't report it well I've
worked with women in who have been
sexually assaulted at the in my prior
career and I've worked with women who
have been abused and I can tell you that
some women do not
forward because they fear not being
believed and I'll tell you a lot of
other women don't come forward John
because of other women you make false
accusations so it cuts both ways many
people say well they wouldn't believe me
because so-and-so like the Duke Lacrosse
accuser who ruined those four boys lives
thank thank God in their adult lives
they're thriving and so there are many
there are many different reasons women
I'll come forward but I think we should
take everything the president said last
week and be fair to the president he has
said from the beginning dr. Ford should
be heard he has said from the beginning
through me and through his own voice
that we should have a process in the
Senate Judiciary Committee so that dr.
Ford can be heard and judge Cavanaugh
can be heard and this Thursday they will
both do exactly that he's very
respectful so Kellyanne do you believe
that Debra Ramirez is confused and made
this up I have no idea what I believe is
what I read Nora which is that she has
said she can't be sure she has said
there are gaps in her own knowledge that
she was she was inebriated that that as
well but she can come and tell that
story
I do think it's very circular though to
have a New Yorker story come out with
much thinner evidence than Ronan Farrow
is used to having in his articles and
then the Democrats saying oh my god look
at this we have to investigate but you
sound Kellyanne there's a great deal of
suspicion you don't believe that there
any that the delay and dr. Ford coming
forward about this in any way challenges
the veracity of her claims that that the
delay just the delay alone does not
raise any questions it does not not to
me I just said John I take these
allegations very seriously as says the
president Killian you say he takes them
very seriously he says I have no doubt
that if the attack on dr. Ford happened
she would have been what did we put up
everything he said last week John be
fair to him this president is defending
his nominee to the United States Supreme
Court that nominee needs to defend
himself against these allegations why
does it not matter to anyone that judge
Kavanagh has said unequivocally and
categorically these allegations are
false
he thinks the latest one show a pattern
of a smear campaign against him and he
has said from the beginning that he
wasn't at the party in question 36 years
ago in
all that has to matter but this
president this president wants them both
to testify in the Senate Judiciary
Committee has set up a process where
they both can I just don't think one man
shoulder should bear decades of the
movement and so we'll and thanks very
much for being with us Kelly